monsieur et madame nirlo accueille
actuellement deux personnes âgées à leur
domicile à bois de nèfles l'accueil
familial est une solution intermédiaire
entre le maintien à domicile et
l'hébergement en établissement en mode
d'accueil qui permet aux personnes qui
ne souhaitent ou qui ne peuvent plus
vivre seul de bénéficier d'un cadre de
vie familiale et de mettre fin à
l'isolément
ce dispositif constitue une priorité du
conseil départemental dans sa politique
en faveur des personnes âgées pour
monsieur madame nirlo devenir
accueillant familial s'est présenté à
eux comme une évidence veulent que les
aides a créé le personnage de chinois
comme j'étais déjà travaillé à l'hôpital
et puis en métropole que je suis arrivé
ici je vous le dis j'ai écouté mes
enfants les petits enfants et plus beau
moment arrêtée en retraite et on voulait
accueillir des personnes les personnes
âgées comme ça je continue de nommer six
mois mais un véritable environnement
familial synonyme de partage et de
solidarité
les accueillit participent à la vie aux
activités de la famille être accueillant
familial est un vrai métier où sont
requises de nombreuses qualités telles
que la patience l'écouté le dialogue et
la tolérance mais juin les chinois le
matin le réveil à 6h30 bénédet là que
jussi réveille tard et montreux vd on
trouve la porte ils viennent après les
flammes hier face à ce secteur sécurisé
me il donne le bain aux patients
accueillis
après moi je prépare le petit déjeuner
l'infini données médicament était en
principe déjeuner après quelques
pronesti dg d'ebay moi je prends inès je
le fais un tour du lotissement marie
thérèse avant le manche est aussi
maintenant ils mangent de moins en moins
après dans l'intérêt je fais que son
ordinateur au mans jusqu'au bout et puis
on revient et la jouanne et b c'est
pareil on défend tous deux minots
d'aquablue me racontent des histoires
aux chocs
il m'aide certes pas les repas
ce mode d'accueil permet aux personnes
âgées de maintenir les liens tissés avec
leur environnement antérieur
les familles des accueillis sont
autorisés à rendre visite mais également
à récupérer leurs proches lors des
week-ends ou des fêtes
mais pour marie thérèse il ya le garçon
qui vient la chercher tous les mercredis
et quand même pour eux chez le médecin
c'est la belle fille qui s'en occupe
keira michel spécialistes c'est elle qui
s'en occupe et mon cher monsieur médecin
traitant et la fille de marie thérèse
qui aiment voir le sentier et il
accueille samedi si elle prend sa maman
si les enfants et petits-enfants de
jacqueline et son époux n'ont pas été
surpris par le souhait de leurs parents
de devenir accueillant familial
désormais pour tout le monde les
personnes accueillies font partie
intégrante de la famille mais ça et
savait déjà parce qu'on avait parlé déjà
parce que savait que c'est un jour
j'aimerais bien faire tout forte sans
âgées accueillies chez moi ils ont bien
ses prix mais mes petits-enfants qui
viennent ici qu'il a mangé le midi mais
pour eux cela m'a mis dix gars tellement
mais c'est moi c'est comme si c'est ma
famille de ma famille c'est ma mamie
c'est je considère qu'en saman les
personnes le conseil départemental
participe à l'aménagement et à
l'accessibilité du domicile
la collectivité met également en place
des formations initiales et continues à
destination des accueillants familiaux